plus que 7 secondes avant l'apocalypse
mais il est encore temps
l'avenir ne dépend que de toi cloud
oh
six mois six mois se sont écoulés depuis
la sortie de final fantasy 7 remake est
quelque chose cloche
vous le savez la saga final fantasy je
la porte dans mon coeur je les ai
toujours crié sur tous les toits
et pourtant silence radio depuis avril
eh bien il existe des sujets où on veut
faire les choses bien voir plus que ça
encore la pression est énorme
les émotions sont présentes et l' envie
d'honorer la saga en beauté est une
priorité
il est temps d'entamer un monument chère
à mon coeur il est temps de parler de
final fantasy 7 remake
déjà il faut poser les bases
[Musique]
ce n'est peut-être pas évident pour
certains mais final fantasy 7 remake est
d'une complexité rare
tout simplement car il n'est pas un
reboot il n'est pas un final fantasy 7
originale en plus beau mais un véritable
deux segments qui sera en plusieurs
morceaux
s'intégrant dans la compilation ff7 une
compilation qui a commencé avec ff7
originel sorti en 1997 et qui a pour but
d'étendre l'univers de final fantasy 7
avec plusieurs oeuvres comme des jeux
vidéo des films ou encore des livres par
moment ce qui logiquement veut dire que
final fantasy 7 remake prend en compte
dans son jeu et ses suites
tous les évènements passés dans la
compilation et c'est quelque chose
d'hyper important à savoir
et pour couronner le tout suite un
remaniement de la compilation pour
justement intégrer le jeu final fantasy
7 remake est considéré par ses créateurs
comme un peu le projet ultime de cette
compilation en étant le cinquième volet
c'est à dire après crisis core before
crisis advent children ainsi que
d'heures jove cerberus
les quatre opus faisant partie
officiellement de la compilation ff7
servant de base mais c'est là où cela
coince un petit peu car est-ce que
l'épopée de final fantasy 7 remake est
le cinquième volet car ce sont les
dernier jeu en date
ou bien parce que chronologiquement
parlant ce jeu et ses futurs partis sont
à la fin malgré le manque de réponse
nous y reviendrons en temps voulu dans
la vidéo mais il est fort à parier que
ce soit chronologiquement est dû à sa
conception
donc en soit on peut le prendre comme
une sorte de conclusion à toutes les
oeuvres proposées en rapport avec
l'univers de final fantasy 7
je ne serai jamais un souvenir
m
[Musique]
je me semble particulièrement obligé de
commencer par le cas de ces féroces car
il est l'antagoniste ultime et iconique
de final fantasy 7 et surtout il est
celui qui apporte le plus de choses dans
ce remake est bon sens nombreux sont les
mystères quel bordel et on en vient aux
problèmes de la compilation où ces
féroces semble possiblement répondre à
la question
tout d'abord l'histoire de ces féroces
et complexe et très sujettes à
l'interprétation dans le final fantasy 7
originel sephiroth n'apparaît pas du
tout dans midgard la première fois que
nous le voyons clairement est à
l'arrivée du groupe à la grotte nord
car oui après avoir commencé à sombrer
dans sa folie en découvrant ses origines
et avoir mis à feu et à sang nibelheim
ces féroces se fera soit disant entre
guillemets tué par cloud dans le
réacteur situé dans les montagnes et
tombera dans la rivière de la vie ou
livestream si vous préférez grâce à sa
volonté de subsister et de devenir une
entité proche d'un dieu sans oublier les
cellules de genova ces féroces a
parcouru le livestream et s'est
reconstitué un corps encore plus
puissant et ceci grâce à la théorie de
la réunion où toutes les cellules de
genova souhaite rejoindre en gros le
vaisseau-mère grossièrement parlant sauf
que justement par sa volonté ses féroces
a même pris le dessus sur genova qui
s'est matérialisée en fosse est féroce
pour se réunir dans ce nouveau corps
sauf que voilà
vous vous souvenez de l'histoire le
groupe et surtout cloud bat sephiroth
sous sa forme
angélique et ce même dans la rivière de
la vie c'est là que cela devient très
intéressant dû à sa défaite c'est féroce
a été détruit ainsi que le météore
envoyé sur terre le météore qui étaient
envoyés pour justement blessé la planète
un tel niveau que ces féroces aurait pu
ne faire qu'un avec et devenir un dieu
pour la terre mais
il a tout perdu et s'est raccrochée à la
dernière chose qu'il pouvait dans le but
de subsister encore et toujours sa haine
pour cloud ne compte pas je ne serai
jamais un souvenir
cloud est relié à ces féroces grâce aux
cellules de genova est donc un souvenir
même après sa mort qui persistent pour
le héros cfi ross est une obsession pour
cloud et inversement
c'est grâce à sa haine et au souvenir
que ces féroces réussira à revenir une
ultime fois dans advent children se
matérialise en grâce à ces derniers et
reprenant sa véritable forme grâce aux
dernières cellules de genova sauf qu'il
sera battu une nouvelle fois mais c'est
féroce veut subsister et c'est une
particularité clé chez le personnage il
est égocentrique il ne tient à rien sauf
à ce qui lui permet d'exister
il veut devenir un dieu pour vaincre la
mort il veut utiliser la planète pour
voyager à travers les univers pour
subsister encore plus et cette
particularité possède une importance
capitale et notre planète fera un jour
partie de tout cela mais moi
je veux subsister dont final fantasy 7
remake c'est féroce apparaît dès le
chapitre 2 sous forme de vision pour
cloud ce dernier lui fera revivre
l'événement tragique de nibelheim le
provoquera en lui rappelant l'assassinât
de sa mère à la première rencontre avec
aeris il lui affirmera qu'il est
incapable de protéger qui que ce soit y
compris lui-même
là où dans l'original cfi ross n'a que
faire de cloud qui n'est pour lui qu'un
pantin jusqu'au moment fatidique de la
fin du jeu dans le remake d les
événements demi de gars est féroce est
déjà dans une démarche de cultive à sion
de la haine chez cloud anvers est féroce
pour qui le haïssent et se souviennent
de lui
voilà c'est très approprié
est ce que vous voyez où je veux en
venir c'est féroce et dans une démarche
de survie poste combat final de final
fantasy 7 original ce qui sous-entend
qu'il s'est déjà fait battre pour
rentrer dans les détails c'est féroce ne
nie pas avoir été tués par cloud
au contraire il ya la présence d'un
double discours ici car cloud fait
référence à nibelheim sauf que ces
féroces souhaité est tombé dans la
rivière de la vie le fait qu'il ne nie
pas ferait référence aux véritables
combats de fin de final fantasy 7 ou cfi
ross a été vaincue et ce même dans le
livestream
d'ailleurs ces féroces n'apparaît qu'au
dessus de cloud jusqu'à la fin du jeu
l'antagoniste à cultiver la haine et les
souvenirs de klout pour réapparaître et
se re matérialisés
grâce à genova autre détail important le
tu es incapable de protéger qui que ce
soit ces féroces mentionne clairement le
destin d'aeris avant de provoquer cloud
de nouveau ce qui sous-entend clairement
qu'il connaît le futur donc nous y voilà
est ce que ces féroces à voyager dans le
temps eh bien c'est ce qu'il semblerait
oui dans l'idée que final fantasy 7
remake soit la conclusion de la
compilation advent children et la
dernière oeuvre ou cefiro sa part m et
pourquoi cela deux ans après la défaite
de ses féroces et la destruction du
météore il ne reste plus rien de la
china a par rufus et les turcs mais ce
n'est pas la question
il ne reste plus qu'un seul vestige de
genova une boîte contenant ces restes
suite à toute l'histoire du film
cfi ross n'a plus aucun moyen de revenir
sauf par le biais de cloud qui est
implicitement la dernière personne
contenant des cellules de genova et
surtout en qui ces féroces des voue une
haine du à sa défaite
cfi ross n'a plus moyen de se re
matérialisés et revenir
il dépend trop de cloud et de ses
souvenirs sauf que si ces féroces ne
peut plus agir avec le temps il ne
restera qu'un simple souvenir et rendant
le livestream
sauf que je ne serai jamais
souvenirs c'est là où l'idée du voyage
dans le temps prend son sens de retour
dans final fantasy 7 remake et ayant
conscience de ses erreurs ses féroces se
sert de cloud pour survivre et revenir
une fois arrivé à terme de l'épisode
midgard sephiroth guidera cloud
affronter le gardien du destin pour
justement le briser et trouver un autre
moyen de subsister car oui pourquoi ces
féroces souhaite défaire le destin est
bien pour en être le maître ou rentrer
dans de l'interprétation personnelle
mais le gardien du destin est en soi une
arme donc une entité défendant la
planète en cas de danger on affronte
d'ailleurs défi leur d'émeraude ruby et
héros faisant directement référence aux
armes déployées par la planète dû à
l'apparition du météore en détruisant
larmes entre guillemets du destin c'est
féroce à ballin destinée qui le mènera à
sa défaite car cloud le vaincra à la fin
et c'est là que l'idée est intéressante
à souligner car ces féroces comme ils
agissaient dans le premier jeu attire
cloud
le guide et le manipule au point de le
faire affronter larmes du destin et donc
libérer ces féroces de sa future défaite
même rouge 13 affirmera en voyant la
vision du futur de lui même qui est
normalement heureuse bac il faut
l'abolir
c'est quoi ce bordel
un aperçu de la réalité qu'on douanes et
entière d'ailleurs si ces féroces
souhaite absolument sauver la planète et
l'a conservée comme il le dit ce sera
certainement car sans planète
impossible pour ces féroces de subsister
et donc de parcourir l'univers avec elle
car évidemment la terre est éphémère
donc il faudra changer de planète à un
moment ou un autre
néanmoins il existe un problème de
taille quelle vision possède square enix
du voyage dans le temps si c'est le cas
est ce que ces féroces en retournant
dans le passé modifiés sont présents
avec ses actes et ses changements
ou est-ce que nous sommes sur une ligne
continue comme dans avengers endgame ou
le passé devient le présent donc
impossible d'inverser le temps il a
besoin d'une nouvelle réalité pour
rebâtir quelque chose est sûre tout cela
veut dire qu'il existe un autre c'est
féroce sommeillant dans la grotte nord
et qu'elle sait firoz subsisterait car
ces féroces est égocentrique je le
rappelle
j'ai gagné
je crois pas
il faut maintenant que nous parlions de
ce bon vieux ac faire quand j'ai
découvert final fantasy 7 remake j'étais
sincèrement heureux je retrouvais les
personnages auxquels je m'étais attaché
je retrouvais les moments iconique du
scénario de base et quelle fut ma
surprise à la dernière heure du jeu où
tout part en vrille
quel concept défi leur de garder le
destin et donc le scénario de base de
final fantasy 7 square enix souhaité
mettre sur la table la question du lien
entre final fantasy vii et final fantasy
7 remake est bien que ce rapport fut
très ambigu jusqu'à de récentes
déclarations il faut l'intégrer final
fantasy 7 remake est une nouvelle
histoire
intégrant la compilation ff7 donc que ce
soit le retour de ces féroces des
milliards la survie de jesse et biggs ou
bien la victoire de zac
chaque élément a son importance et les
réponses arriveront avec les prochains
jeux alors essayons de deviner ce que
tout cela signifie pour revenir plus
précisément sur ac c'est peut-être idiot
mais si ff7 remake nous montre que suite
à l'abolition du destin sachs survie
c'est que cela à une nécessité dans le
scénario
remémorez-vous l'histoire du personnage
zac est un soldat première classe de la
shinra il collaborera à de nombreuses
reprises avec ses féroces suite à la
désertion de genesis et angie deux
autres soldats qui ont fui suite à la
découverte de leur origine il s'avère
que la shinra effectué des expériences
avec les cellules de genova pour créer
des super guerrier et accessoirement des
abominations de la nature après de
nombreuses péripéties auzac enchaînera
révélation rencontre avec cloud ou aeris
affrontement contre angie halle ou
encore genesis nous arrivons à
l'incidence de nibelheim ces féroces
fera lui aussi l'objet de la découverte
de ses origines et
perdre à la raison zac tentera de
l'arrêter mais échouera lourdement et
c'est cloud simples fantassins qui
réussira à le faire tomber avant de
succomber lui aussi la shinra souhaitant
étoffer la sphère et la cacher fera
reconstruire nibelheim et engagera des
comédiens pour peupler la ville cloud et
zach étant condamnés seront transférées
au manoir chinois ou le professeur aux
jo tentera d expérience sur ces deux
nouveaux sujets la fameuse théorie de la
réunion c'est après quatre années de
coma que zac se réveillera et réussir à
s'enfuir
l'expérience sera un échec vu qu'il est
déjà un soldat première classe liées à
la maco il libérera cloud mais ce
dernier fera l'objet d'un empoisonnement
à la mac os et aux cellules de genova et
en maintenant des fugitifs zac a pour
idée de retourner à miss gard pour
retrouver aeris avec qui il s'est lié et
devenir un mercenaire avec son ami cloud
sauf que la fuite du manoir chinois se
fera savoir et c'est lors d'un ultime
affrontement que zac mourra les gants la
buster sword a cloud qui deviendra
l'héritage vivant de zac
vraiment au moins noyer qui tend en
tension
et c'est là toute l'importance
scénaristique de zac cloud duo
traumatisme qu'il a subie à nibelheim
les expériences d'autres joe son
empoisonnement à la maco pendant quatre
longues années et la mort de son
meilleur ami sous ses yeux s'effondrera
à son arrivée à la gare de la section 7
et entremêlera tous ses souvenirs avec
ceux de zac cloud n'a jamais été un
soldat première classe
il n'a jamais été le confrère d'armes de
ces féroces toute l'intrigué du jeu
repose là-dessus et c'est pourquoi la
survie de zac questionne beaucoup et si
c'était à cause de ces féroces comme je
vous l'expliquais dans la première
théorie ces féroces à manipuler cloud
comme dans le jeu original et l'a fait
cette fois-ci affronter le gardien du
destin en se libérant du joug du destin
c'est féroce aurait libéré également zac
de son destin tragique empêchant donc
cloud de construire son histoire et de
devenir qui il deviendra karoui qui est
l'ennemi ultime de ces féroces
celui qui l'a vaincu deux fois de suite
c'est cloud s'ils voyagent longtemps il
y a sephiroth aurait possiblement voulu
changer l'histoire à sa racine pour
avoir le terrain libre et mener à bien
sa quête pour devenir un dieu et
subsister à travers les âges et là où
cela m'a paru évident et lorsque j'ai
appris que ff7 remake faisait partie de
la compilation car nous avions toujours
le doute de 6 square enix prendrait en
compte les autres jeux mais là c'est
officiel et surtout nous avons la
présence de personnages comme leslie
khairi ou encore l' ange gardien qui
font tous partie d'un livre the kids are
all right qui faisait partie de la
compilation
donc vous l'avez compris tout ce qui a
existé dans l'univers existe bel et bien
dans le remake et ça va continuer et est
bon c'est une idée un peu folle mais le
fait de garder à caen vie nous
permettrait d'appréhender une autre
histoire avec ce personnage
une histoire ou cloud n'est jamais
devenu celui que nous connaissons par le
biais d'une autre dimension
celle qu'un avec la preuve de la
mascotte storm qui est différente
nous pourrions avoir des phases de
gameplay avec zac dans midgard et qui
s'est même peut-être que ce serait lui
qui vaincrait le cfi rose de cette
réalité
bref en fait si je m'envole peut être un
peu beaucoup c'est que la saga du remake
sera longue et conséquente plusieurs
jeux sont prévus et toute la compilation
est prise en compte
square enix n'a pas caché vouloir
introduire de nouveaux personnages comme
roche ou faire revenir d'anciens comme
leslie khairi etc
l'univers de final fantasy 7 est rempli
de trous à combler et d'éléments qui
manquent de précision maintenant que
square enix a fait plaisir aux fans de
la première heure ils vont pouvoir
balancer de la nouveauté
ils veulent amener de nouveaux lieux de
nouvelles intrigues de nouvelles
histoires
bien évidemment on restera toujours basé
sur l'histoire de base de final fantasy
sinon l'intriguent des gardiens du
destin et le côté remake n'a plus
d'intérêt mais ac est un personnage qui
a eu une histoire qui s'est stoppée
soudainement zac a encore beaucoup de
choses à nous montrer
et c'est là je pense l'intérêt de square
enix si ces féroces a brisé le destin
pour empêcher cloud de devenir qui il
est il est fort à parier que les
prochains jeux nous montrerons deux
dimensions qui se croiseraient au fil de
l'histoire de réalité un ennemi commun
imaginez un combat réunissant ac et
cloud contre un cypher c'est féroce
encore plus puissant que dans le premier
je
[Musique]
je pensais à la base vous proposer une
troisième théorie tournant autour
d'aeris nomura ne le cache pas à
hérisser d'après lui le personnage le
plus important du remake et de ses
suites
mais en même temps c'est normal aeris
est la dernière des c'est rare un peuple
très ancien qui communiquait avec la
planète et 10 effet décimée par
l'arrivée de genova sur la planète
son rôle est capital ainsi que sa mort
déjà par le biais de l'invocation au lit
pour contrer le météore envoyés par ces
féroces mais aussi car avec son
sacrifice aeris agira et sauvera le
monde depuis le livestream pour détruire
le météore et dans le remake
elle semble aussi avoir des prédictions
sur l'avenir et en sait beaucoup sur ces
féroces
néanmoins nous avons trop peu d'éléments
pour le moment peut-être que ce sera
l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo
a vous de me dire en commentaire
yark sokhna y as des as à l'autre kimi
no tax passionnés canada's maemo de la
genesis rhapso dos est un soldat de
première classe qui combattaient aux
côtés de ces féroces et angie ils
étaient tous les trois les meilleurs
guerriers de la shinra et s'apprécier
beaucoup malheureusement contrairement à
ses deux compères qui possèdent des
cellules de genova dès la naissance
genesys a subi une injection de ces
dernières quand il était très jeune une
injection mal effectué qui aura pour
conséquence une dégradation génétique du
personnage c'est à cause de ça qu'il fit
la découverte de ses origines et déserta
la shinra pour se rebeller contre elle
suite à ces actions et la recherche
d'une solution contre la dégradation
genesis révéla l'origine des projets de
la shinra entourant genova à nge il est
bien évidemment assez féroce qui comme
vous le savez perdit la raison suite à
ça
la particularité de genesis et qu'il est
obsédé par un livre de poésie qui sera
adapté en pièce musicale amis car loeb
laisse et l'histoire de loveless conte
l'histoire de trois hommes en quête du
don de la déesse pareil vous connaissez
l'histoire du jeu genesys pris au pied
de la lettre
l'histoire de l'homme laisse et fut en
quête de ce fameux don de la ds après sa
défaite face à zach genesis se fera
recueillir par nero et weys deux super
soldat du dit brown
une garde très secrète cachée dans les
fins fonds de midgard par le président
lui-même
nero et wes voulait recruter genesis à
leur côté pour effectuer une rébellion
sauf que ce dernier déclina l'offre est
ce c'est là dans une caverne de midgard
après les événements de days of cerberus
et la destruction d'oméga genesis
réapparaîtra devant le corps de wale et
l'emmènera affirmant il n'est pas
l'heure de s'endormir
nous avons encore beaucoup à accomplir
bien il y a des choses à dire
évidemment si je parle de genesis ce
n'est pas pour rien depuis des années un
énorme mystère entoure ce personnage le
truc avec genesis et qu'il apparaît dans
créé
ce corps qui est chronologiquement
parlant le premier jeu de la compilation
ff7 et réapparaîtra dans la toute
dernière scène de giorgio of cerberus le
tout dernier jeu de la chronologie
c'est un élément qui est très important
à souligner car tout le long de
l'histoire de la compilation genesis
n'est pas mort il sommeille dans les
bas-fonds 2000 car ce qui signifie qu'il
a encore une utilité scénaristique
bon c'est bien tout ça mais quel est le
rapport avec le remake après sa défaite
face à zach une déesse apparu face à
genesis cette dernière soigne à sa
dégradation est le repoussa afin de lui
faire comprendre qu'il a encore beaucoup
à apprendre et à accomplir
le truc c'est que cette déesse qui a
pour nom minerva est la première
véritable apparition divine de la série
nous savons que dans l'univers de ff7
les setra pouvez communiquer avec la
planète que ses féroces et en combat
avec la planète
mais tout ça c'est implicite c'est
ambigu
la planète est personnifié comme mère
nature et sert d'anthropomorphisme sauf
que là la planète se représente
elle-même par le biais d'une image de ds
et ed genesis grâce à la rivière de la
vie il y a une signification derrière
tout ça genesis est devenu un protecteur
de la planète
la voilà la signification genesis n'est
pas forcément quelqu'un de mauvais il
est avant tout une victime des
expériences de la shinra et en a
beaucoup souffert après que minerva lui
soit apparue sa dégradation s'est arrêté
et ça raison lui est revenu si je suis
en mesure de vous affirmer ceci c'est
grâce au guide complet de crisis core
qui affirme que genesis est revenue
d'andorge of cerberus pour protéger la
planète
c'est là que c'est interpellant car
comme je vous le disais derja observé
russe est le dernier jeu de la
compilation dans la chronologie et nous
arrivons maintenant à effet cette remake
se plaçant normalement après c'est un
mystère qui existe depuis des années
pourquoi genesis se réveillent
maintenant pour protéger la planète et
si c'était à cause de ces féroces je
vous la firme depuis le début
je suis partisan d'un ces féroces qui
auraient voyagé dans le temps pour
réparer ses erreurs de parcours
ce dernier est capable d'ouvrir une
dimension menant au gardien du destin ou
même au début de la création de
l'univers le truc c'est que ces féroces
et genesis sont intimement liés où
étaient tous deux des soldats légendaire
et ont perdu la raison
néanmoins après toutes ces péripéties
genesis est considéré aujourd'hui comme
un protecteur de la planète et ses
féroces comme l'ennemi de cette dernière
c'est là que cela m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille et si à la fin de jawf
cerberus genesis partirait voyager dans
le temps au service de la planète pour
défaire ces féroces qui la menacent de
nouveau alors très bien mais pourquoi
at-il emmené wells avec lui c'est une
question intéressante
attention je le rappelle une fois de
plus mais tout ceci n'est que mon
interprétation personnelle et mes idées
dans dirt of cerberus aux jo a fait des
expériences sur waits pour qu'ils
puissent être en mesure d'évoquer oméga
larmes ultime de la planète qui sert de
dernier recours quand toute la vie sur
cette dernière est menacée je vous
épargne les détails
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas toutes les
ficelles mais oméga absorbera toute la
vie de la planète pour rebâtir un
nouveau cycle
car comme vous le savez la terre est
éphémère et mourra un jour cependant la
vie trouve toujours son chemin
bref white invoquera oméga mais échouera
face à vincent et genesis recueillera
son corps inconscients et si genesis
emmené wes avec lui pour justement
invoqué oméga dans la saga ffvii remake
je veux dire la planète elle s'en fiche
que cloud existe qu à iris existe tout
ce qui compte c'est que la vie continue
ces féroces étant une menace récurrente
est très dangereuse pour la planète
genesys pourrait avoir comme solution
d'invoquer oméga pour se débarrasser à
tout jamais de ces féroces grâce à wells
de plus cette idée permettrait de mettre
en lumière des éléments de deurne of
cerberus dans le remake cloud et son
groupe ne serait évidemment pas d'accord
avec ceux ci et combattrez également
genesys
nous aurions donc un triangle
d'affrontements entre cloud sephiroth et
genesis mais je vous la corde cette idée
est un petit peu folle le truc c'est que
genesis a ouvert une porte dans dirt
observé russe une porte qui ne s'est
jamais refermée
si ff7 remake en est la suite et la fin
il faudra la ferme et à un moment ou un
autre
norm merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo ce n'est peut-être pas grand-chose
pour vous mais c'est un projet qui me
tenait réellement à coeur après
plusieurs mois de réflexion de recherche
d'interprétation je suis très heureux
d'être allé au bout vive final fantasy
alors je vous le demande si vous
souhaitez me soutenir n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleu un
commentaire à partager la vidéo et
surtout vous abonner à la chaîne si ce
n'est pas déjà fait d'ailleurs sachez
que j'ai repris ma chaîne secondaire
totalement orientée sur la saga ff
voilà j'ai hâte de vous re proposer de
telles vidéos comme celle ci 100%
passion cet argot rock et que le
lionheart soit avec vous
[Musique]